ROBERT KUBIS: OK.
Let's try that again.
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
That's as much Italian
that I can speak.
Thank you for joining me for
this talk this afternoon.
With the looming weather
that is coming up,
I really appreciate that you
made your way here to my talk.
What am I going to
talk about today
is Google Cloud Spanner, a
horizontally global distributed
relational database.
And I'm going to talk a
little bit in more detail how
everything works.
But before that, I want
to put a couple of words
to my person in terms of like
what my job at Google is.
I'm a developer
advocate at Google.
And we understand
our job as being
a bi-directional
interface, so to say,
between developers that
build on our products
and the developers
within Google that
build the products for you.
So please, feel free to reach
out to me on Twitter or GitHub
if you have
constructive feedback,
if you have some ideas what you
want to do with Google Cloud
platform or certain products.
And we are happy to be
there for you to respond to.
Now, what am I going to cover
today, in this talk is I
want to give a brief
history about how Spanner
was built within Google
and why it was built.
I'm going to go
a little bit more
in detail about what is the
added feature set in terms
of Cloud Spanner, like what
are adding to the version
that we have, internally?
And then I will
spend a fair amount
on explaining the inner workings
of Spanner and give a demo.
Now, why did we build Spanner?
Let's go back about 12 years.
And Google has
been at that point
running on top of
a charted MySQL.
So we had a database,
which was charted
based on the customer ID.
Our [? S ?] business
was running through it.
And there are a lot of millions
of dollars, basically, backed
on this charted MySQL system.
Now, since we were
growing really fast,
we had to basically rechart
that database multiple times.
And the last time we
recharted that database,
it took over two years
to rechart that database.
So clearly, this
was not a solution
that we could go forward
in the terms of scalability
that we needed.
So what did we really
need from a database
where lots of
customers are basically
betting their money on?
So we had customers
with budgets.
We had our own systems
that needed, basically,
transactional consistency
as a back end.
So we needed a database
which scales horizontally,
which supports
ACID transactions,
and most importantly, that can
support no downtime, updates
of security updates,
and schema updates
and things like that
because every time,
we basically had to
shut down our back end,
it would be a loss of money for
us and lots of our customers,
as well.
So this was not acceptable.
Also, because we were
dealing with people's money,
eventual consistency was not
acceptable for us either.
So fast forward
about 10, 12 years
that we were running Cloud
Spanner inside of Google.
We made it now
available for all of you
to basically use it
with your applications.
But we added a couple
of things which we think
are really important
for Cloud Solution
to offer that under the
portfolio of Google Cloud
platform.
So one of the very first
things is Google Cloud Spanner
comes as a fully
managed service.
It is the same back end,
the same engineering,
the same technology that we
use internally for our Spanner.
But you get it, basically,
through a UI, fully managed,
very easy to set up, and
then, within seconds,
available for you.
It's still the same performance
and global consistency
that we have inside.
Also, what is
really important is
we wanted to meet people
and developers where
they are in terms of
familiarity with interacting
with relational databases.
So Spanner supports the familiar
SQL and the 2011 standard
that has traditional relational
semantics and ACID semantics.
Also, Spanner supports
an automatic [? V ?]
synchronous replication for
regional and multiregional
setups.
And it is battle
tested within Google
for more than five years.
Now, for regional setups,
we provide, actually,
four nines availability, which
boils down to 4 minutes and 38
seconds, roughly,
of unavailability
that we accept for
a regional setup.
Later this year, we will
support a multiregional setup
that can span the
globe, where you
get five nines of availability
for that setup, which basically
boils down to about 26 seconds
per month in unavailability
that we guarantee.
Now, another thing which
was really important for us
was when we were working with
our early access customers
to help them integrate
Cloud Spanner
into their applications.
So we were looking
at this like, OK,
how can we make it
as easy as possible
to adapt Cloud Spanner?
One I already mentioned was
SQL, that we support SQL
and that we support one SQL
standard across our product
portfolio.
So there has been, in the
past, multiple SQL dialects.
We now switched to SQL ANSI
2011 across our portfolio.
So BigQuery, as also
Spanner, supports ANSI 2011.
For all of our data that
is stored in Spanner,
it is encrypted at
rest and in flight.
And we added things like
audit locking and integration
of our IAM, so our Identity
and Access Management,
so that you can control
access to data within Spanner.
With the launch, we provide,
also, the client library system
in four languages.
And we are working hard on
more languages to add to this.
So currently, we have Java,
Go, Python, and Node.js
as the languages that you can
use today, out of the box.
We also have a REST API
and a [? GOPC ?] step
if you want to build
your own client libraries
in a different language.
And we provide a
read-only JDBC driver
to integrate with
things like BI tools
from partners and
things like that.
So how does Spanner compare
to a traditional database
or a non-SQL scalable database?
If you look at Spanner,
in one sentence,
I would describe it
as you get relation--
like a database
with the semantics
of a relational database with
the scalability of a NoSQL
database.
So what does that mean?
Spanner provides you things like
a strong schema, strong type
schema, provides you
SQL, which a lot of you
probably are familiar with.
It provides you
strong consistency.
And the way that Spanner
works behind the scenes,
adds all the things like high
availability and horizontal
scalability.
All the data is automatically
replicated to read replicas.
And also, I will
go into more detail
in terms of the
architecture, like how
we achieve the high availability
and the horizontal scalability.
Now, some might say, OK,
some-- many of these things
I can get from a traditional
relational database as well.
So, yes, but many scenarios.
If you look at
scalability, for instance,
you look at a scenario
where you, for instance,
have a charted MySQL
or charted Postgres.
Now, if you want to
get scalability there,
there are certain
things that you can do.
For once, you can,
for instance, add
some read replicas to offload
some workload from your master,
and by that, scale more for
your rights on your master.
But you basically have
to hope that your cloud
provider or your
machine producer
gives you a bigger machine
as your system is growing,
as your business is growing.
So you kind of run out
of head space eventually,
at some point, in the
terms of the amount of data
that you can manage with a
traditional relational database
or the amount of reads
and writes that you
can handle with that system.
Now, also, oftentimes, if you
go into the charted world off of
or Postgres, you lose a lot of
the qualities of the underlying
database system.
And a lot of the
semantics, you have
to put up into your
business logic, which makes
the whole system very complex.
So now, with Spanner,
you basically
can put this logic
back into the database.
And you don't have to care
in your application layer
about it.
Now, comparing to
a non-SQL database,
you basically don't
have these things
where you have tweakable
consistency, where
you might have to deal
with eventual consistency
for a Cassandra or MongoDB
or things like that.
So we basically have
given the highest standard
of serializability with Spanner,
external serializability.
And there's no way around that.
That's basically what you
get and you'll always have.
Now, if we look at
the typical workloads
where Spanner is used, I want
to emphasize on two areas
where Spanner is really strong.
One is, I mentioned, no
downtime, schema and security
updates behind the
scenes, basically,
for Spanner, which makes Spanner
a very high available system.
So if you have a system
which is mission critical,
where you cannot accept
any downtime, Spanner--
even if you have not a lot of
data, Spanner is your choice.
That's something where
you should look into.
Another thing is in terms of
scalability for read/writes
and data size.
So if you want to
scale horizontally
for your reads and
writes in transactions,
Spanner is, again, a very
good solution for this.
You won't get the very
low latency query times
you might get with some of the
vertical scalable solutions.
But in the end, if you
design your database well
from a schema and
query standpoint,
you can basically,
with adding nodes,
scale very well horizontally.
And you don't get the
hockey stick at the end
if you get out of
capacity on your nodes.
So things where we
see a lot of usage
for these kinds of
workloads is, for instance,
like financial system,
inventory management,
where you need kind of like
a global consistent database,
and things where you need
a lot of reads and writes.
For a matter of fact, if
you look at the global data
plane, Google Cloud
platform, everything
in terms of the management
of resources and APIs
and virtual machines
is backed by Spanner
as a global data plane.
Another use case that
we see and that you
can use Spanner for since
it's scalable in terms
of the size of
data it can handle
is database consolidation.
So instead of running
your daily ATL
drops of extracting them
data from a No-SQL solution,
and then extracting
some account data
from your relational
database, and then running
some analytics on
that, you can basically
think of putting all this
data into one database
without the hassle of
having ATLs everywhere.
So with that, I
want to look into,
how does Spanner actually
achieve these things
that I just claimed?
I claimed horizontal
scalability.
I claimed that it can
grow in database size
up to terabytes and petabytes.
And I claimed that it can handle
a lot of read and write loads.
So the way that
Spanner is doing this
is a separation of
compute versus storage.
So if you look here, this is
an example of a regional setup.
So I have a regional instance.
I create that regional instance
in one of my preferred regions.
And when I start
and buy three nodes,
I get, actually, behind
the scenes, nine nodes.
So all the three
nodes that I buy
are replicated three
times in three zones.
Now, in each of the zones,
I have storage, basically,
so the storage is
replicated as well.
Now, if you look at the
terminology in terms
of what are the visible
items for Spanner database
and instance from a client side
and what is behind the scenes
to enable the
horizontal scalability,
we start with an instance
that we just saw.
So you basically set up
your regional instant
that defines how many
nodes you have, how many--
where this region,
instance lives.
Or later in this year, we
have a multiregional instance.
So you can decide where your
multiregional instance lives.
In each of these instances, you
can create multiple databases,
up to 100 databases.
And then in each database,
you create tables,
as we are familiar with from a
MySQL database, for instance.
Now, these tables are--
behind the scenes,
we split these
tables by key ranges.
And the splits are done based
on the primary key and by range.
Now, what enables
this splitting?
The splitting enables us
to horizontal the scale.
So how do we do this?
Basically, the computer
sources that we
have available in
our regional instance
are responsible for
multiple splits.
So the splits are basically
parts of data in your database.
Now, basically, a split
is part of a table.
Now, we see that in
all of these regions,
we basically have a
compute node or computer
source which is responsible for
split one here in this example.
And we have a Paxos group formed
by these three compute nodes
that are responsible
for the split one.
Now, we use Paxos to select
a leader in this group.
And now, once we
have this leader,
we can make sure
that only one compute
node is responsible for--
and gating, basically,
writes write transaction
on that data piece.
By that, we can make sure that
we have global consistency
because there's never two
leaders for a database.
Now, you could imagine,
in a distributed world,
this would incur a
lot of communication
to make sure that we have, at
most, one responsible compute
node for a data piece.
The way that we remove some
of this communication overhead
is with an innovation that we
specifically did for Spanner.
And it is called TrueTime.
Now, what is TrueTime?
Imagine you're sitting
next to your neighbor,
and you're trying to
synchronize your watches.
Now, you go off and meet
again in a couple of hours.
You have been exposed to
different temperatures,
different [? ionospheric ?]
rays and things like that.
Your clocks will drift
away from each other.
So it's really hard, actually,
to synchronize clocks,
even in a small
vicinity of a room.
Now, think of synchronizing
clocks globally
across data centers.
Now, TrueTime
actually achieves that
by a very smart technology
and semantic way.
What TrueTime does
is, actually, we
use GPS to synchronize our
data centers clockwise.
And we use atomic
clocks in these data
centers to basically keep
a very accurate time.
Now, still, we cannot use just
a single timestamp to make sure
that this timestamp is the
exact timestamp everywhere
in the world.
We have to quantify an interval,
which basically gives us
the uncertainty
of this timestamp.
What does that mean?
A lot of words.
It basically means we get,
with TrueTime, a lower bound
and an upper bound
of a timestamp.
The lower bound
of the timestamps
tells us that this timestamp has
passed everywhere in the world.
The upper bound of
that interval gives us
a timestamp which tells us this
timestamp definitely hasn't
passed anywhere in the world.
Now, with these
two timestamps, we
can make sure that there's
only one leader, exactly
one leader for a database.
And by that, we get the
external serializability
for our transactions
that we provide.
Now, in terms of the interval,
how long is that, roughly?
In our paper, we
published that it's
in the single-digit milliseconds
interval in terms of the lower
bound and the upper bound.
Now, what happens if, for
instance, in my data center,
all atomic clocks fail
and all GPS fails?
What happens in this
case is that we actually
go to a different data
center to get this TrueTime.
And we will calculate in
the travel time of the data,
basically from our data center
to the next data center.
Now, with that, the
interval basically widens,
and the database slows down.
But the database doesn't stop.
So that is really important.
The database, even in the case
that we lose atomic clocks
or we lose GPS in a data
center, the database
will continue working
and will continue
working in a very consistent--
global consistent rate.
So let's demonstrate
that on a query.
Here in this example, I
select from my event table
all the events that have
the name Next Milan.
So in a consistent
read scenario,
I basically send the
request from my client.
And in this case, it comes
in through my read replica.
And the read replica will go
to the leader for that data
piece in my Paxos group
and will ask, hey,
do I have the latest data?
It basically sends the
timestamp of the data
that the read
replica already has.
Now, the leader will respond,
yes, you have the latest data.
And the data will be served
from my read replica.
In the case that the read
replica doesn't have the most
recent data, the leader
will just respond, no,
you don't have the data.
Just wait until timestamp, and
once you see that timestamp,
you can respond to data.
The reason is that the
data is already in flight
when this question
is basically asked.
So we don't need to
send the data back,
even if the read replica
doesn't have the latest data.
So we basically just
wait out that time.
We basically wait
until that timestamp,
our upper bound
timestamp in TrueTime,
wait out that time that
we got from the leader.
And once we have that
timestamp, and we have the data,
we can basically respond.
Now, we also support something
called stale or inconsistent
reads, time bound reads.
When are these useful?
Imagine you have a
multiregional setup.
And this is globally distributed
between the US, Europe,
and Asia.
Now, time bounded queries
gives you the possibility
to basically read data that
is a little bit older in a way
that you say, OK, I accept data
that is up to 15 seconds old.
Now, in that case,
the read replica
can check, do I have data that
is, at most, 15 seconds old?
And if that is the
case, it basically
can respond immediately
without consulting
the leader of that
data piece, which
could go across the
ocean in some cases
to check if that data is
actually the most recent one.
Now, what happens in the
read/write transaction?
In a read/write transaction,
when I start that transaction,
and I basically do-- within the
read/write transaction context,
I do a query, I'm directly
routed to the leader of that
Paxos group of that for--
which is responsible
for that data piece.
Now, the leader will acquire
locks, return the results.
I do some modification on that.
And then I'm sending,
basically, the modifications
to the leader.
And the leader will send
out the modification
to the group, the Paxos group.
Once the leader receives a
majority of acknowledgement
from all the participants
in that group,
it considers this
transaction committed,
we'll basically release the
locks and return to the client
a success of that transaction.
If you look at the data
layout, which Spanner supports,
I mentioned that it supports
traditional SQL and CSQL
in the same way as
other databases.
So we also have the
relational model
set you're familiar with,
with strongly typed schemas,
relational schemas,
so you see here,
creating a singles table and
an album table with an ID
and some single name
and an album ID.
Now, if you look at
databases like MySQL,
you have things like
foreign key constraints
or referential integrity that
you can get through that.
We don't support that in
the distributed system.
But we have something
which is basically
a foreign key
constraint-- minus, minus.
And that is called
interleaved tables.
What are interleaved tables?
Now, interleaved tables give
you co-located data locality
in the sense of, here,
I have my singers table,
and I have my album table, and
I interleave that album table
into my singers table.
Now, all this data
is basically put
in one split that
I talked about,
which is a part of that table.
It will be put all
in one split per row.
So you have the
Beatles, for an example.
And every album for
the Beatles will
be living in the same
split as the row, the--
where the Beatles lives in.
And that gives you
kind of like a bridge
or in terms of
like that joins can
be answered very quickly
from one compute node that
is controlling and
responsible for that split.
So if we do this for our data
models that we have just seen,
we basically just
add an interleave in.
And we have to make sure that
the interleaved table shares
the primary keys
of the outer table.
And then we can basically
interleave the table.
Also, what is really
important here
is that we support no
downtime schema updates.
So you can add columns.
You can change size
attributes of columns.
So it can go from a string 20 to
a string 50, things like that.
All these schema updates run,
actually, in a transaction.
So there are a couple
of things that you
have to be aware
of when you migrate
from a traditional MySQL
database or Postgres or any
of the major, bigger database
vendors to Cloud Spanner
to keep the scalability.
Now, one of the things is
that like our heavily used
or that, many times, are used
in a traditional database
are things like outer and
command ID as a primary key.
Now, this is actually
poison for Spanner in terms
of the horizontal scalability.
And I will get into a little
bit more detail about that.
So don't use any
monotonic increasing
or decreasing primary keys.
Don't use any timestamps as
primary keys in your schema.
Also, be careful in terms of
how much you use interleaving.
I mentioned all of
this lives, basically,
in the split of the
parent table, which
means if you interleave
huge tables into one
row of your parent
table, you also run out
of capacity in terms of
resources for that node that
is handling that split.
So if you look at
using, for instance,
timestamps for a primary key,
what you would end up with
is hotspotting one
of your compute nodes
in managing that data.
So imagine you're
loading your database
and you're putting the
timestamp as the primary key.
What you end up with is
that all your new data
that you load into the
database ends in the last split
of your table.
And the last split is handled
by one computer source.
Now, to avoid this,
you can do things
like using new IDs, version 4,
or you're using charting IDs.
So what does that look like?
If you look-- and everything
is also on our documentation.
You'll find more
detailed explanation
about how you can optimize
your schemas and your workloads
to not bottleneck on
hotspot on certain things.
Now, if you, for instance,
use a charting ID,
what it will look like is we
now prefix our primary key
with a charting ID.
And by that, we enable to
spread out the workload
across multiple compute
resources, as you can see here.
With this, I want to
go in a little demo.
Are we switched?
Perfect.
So your first stop point, if you
want to learn more about Cloud
Spanner and if you want to
get your hands on the Spanner,
is cloud.google.com/spanner,
where you'll find a multitude
of resources around
documentation, how to use it,
but also things
like case studies.
As you can see down here,
we have a case study
with [? Quizlet ?] that moved
and migrated from charted MySQL
to Spanner and does
a lot of analytics
around what did we have to
change in our applications
to do this migration?
I'm also asked quite a couple
of times today already,
does Spanner defeat
the CAP Theorem?
Spanner does not
defeat the CAP Theorem.
And you can read in detail
around a take of the inventor
of the CAP Theorem, Eric
Brewer, a take on that in terms
of like in contrast to Spanner.
But basically, what I can say
is Spanner is a CP system.
But the infrastructure that
supports Spanner within Google
has not failed us in
the way that we did not
have a network partition so
far with our internal Spanner
system.
So the strong infrastructure
that we have within Google
basically gives
us the reliability
and just a very
unlikely scenario
of a partitioning where
we would, in that case,
result to a consistent system
and would become unavailable.
Now, for a regional
setup, we basically
give an SLA for four nines,
and for a multiregional setup,
we give an SLA of five nines
of availability for this.
Now, if you want to get
started with Spanner,
the first thing that you
do is create your instance.
And that couldn't be easier
than doing Spanner Playground,
giving it a name.
It automatically gives
you an instance ID.
You choose one of the four
regions that we currently
support, which is basically
in Asia, East and Northeast,
so Taiwan and Japan, and
also Europe and Belgium,
and US in Iowa.
So, for example, I
will choose Europe.
You choose the amount of nodes
that you want to start with.
You click Create, and within
seconds, you have an error.
Oh.
All right.
Let's see if I have enough
quota to have at least one node.
Awesome.
OK.
So I didn't have enough
quota for 10 nodes,
but I have at least enough
quota for one node here.
So now you have your instance.
and you basically can start
creating your database.
So you can choose a
normal DDL, SQL DDL.
Or you can use our editor
here in the console
to create your table.
Now, for the demo purpose,
I use this UI editor.
I'm adding some
information, primary key,
selecting my age
as a primary key.
And I create this table.
And within a couple of
clicks, I have a database
where I can run queries
against and I can also
check the schema.
Now, I mentioned online updates.
So I can, for instance,
add another column.
And I forgot the
name of the singer.
I want to give it a string.
And let's say 100
characters should be enough.
I can save this.
And if I reload this
page, you can see here
that we instantly see that this
schema update is in progress.
Now, this is done
in a transaction.
So basically at a
specific timestamp,
you will have that
new schema available,
and you can accommodate
that in your application.
Now, if you joined the
keynote this morning,
you might have seen or are
familiar with this schema.
So I built a ticket
broker system,
so to say, where I have a ticket
database where I'm selling
tickets all around the world.
And what's really
important in this case
is that I sell each
ticket only once.
I also wanted to
have a system which
is as realistic as possible.
So in this database,
we basically
have an event table,
which shows all our events
that are happening
around the world.
And we have different
seating categories and venues
that these events
are happening in.
So you can think of a
VIP seating, a premium
seating, general seating.
And then once this event
is actually happening,
I attach, also, some
prices to these categories.
So we have a ticket
category table.
And at the end, we also have--
for each of these tickets that
are available in our system,
we have a ticket in
our ticket table.
So for the demo database that we
used today in our keynote demo,
we have, actually, about 2
billion rows, 2 billion tickets
available in the database.
Now, this database
runs right now live.
And in this query, I want to
select all the events that
are happening from now until
tomorrow evening, tomorrow
night.
So I want to see what events
are still happening in Italy
and what are the
available seats.
Now, when I run this query,
it will take a while.
And it will give me the
result of like all the events
that I have and all the
tickets that are available.
And as you can see,
the seats available
is a little lower than the
total seats are available.
So this database is actually
live, running right now.
What you can do,
as well is you can
get an explanation, a
query plan of the query
that you just executed.
So what you see here
is, for instance,
the CPU time that was needed.
You see the rows that was
returned for this query.
And you see the rows
that were scanned.
Now, I'm a bit familiar
with this query
because I designed it.
And I see there's a lot
of rows scanned here.
And I think that's way too many.
And if I go through
my query plan,
I can see that I'm doing a
table scan on my event table.
Now, you might have seen it.
You might have missed it.
In my query, I actually had
a filter based on a timing.
And it should be
able to do something
smarter than a table
scan on my event table.
For a matter of fact,
if we look at the event
table on the left
side, we're seeing
that I have some indexes
defined in my table.
So I talked about extensions,
SQL ANSI 2011 with extensions.
So one of the things
that you can do,
which you can do, also,
for many other databases,
is to give the compiler, the
query compiler and optimizer,
a hint.
So in this case, I
want to force an index.
And I have event by
date here as my index
and say, OK, please use
this index right now.
And as we can see, the
query got a lot faster.
And if we go into
the explanation,
I'm now down to
4,000 rows scanned
instead of 400,000 rows.
So you have the possibility
to also use the extension
that you provide to
improve your queries
and optimize your queries.
Now, if you want to get
started with Cloud Spanner,
one of the ways that
you can get started with
is our Java client library.
And I kind of walked
through a small example
here for our Java
client library.
In this case, I'm
using a demo database.
And the first thing
that I would have to do
is basically get some
credentials and authentication
against my database.
If you run that locally
with our G Cloud SDK setup,
you basically live in the
context, the authentication
context, of your G Cloud CLI.
So I'm basically just getting
these application default
credentials.
And the next thing
that I'm doing
is setting the instance ID
that I need and the database ID
that I want to talk to.
Now, my first example
that I want to do here
is I want to do a
read-only transaction.
So I get a transaction context.
And I execute a query.
Now, this query, what
it does is it basically
selects all the marquee events
that are happening today
to tomorrow.
So you have some
parameter placeholders,
which I'm binding in my query
down here, in my statement
builder.
Now the last thing--
as you can see, I'm already
executing the queries there.
The last thing that I
want to do is already
going through my results set.
So I'm going to
iterate, basically,
through my result
set that I'm getting.
And I am fetching the results.
So here I can do a get string.
And I can use either
positional arguments
or I can use the column
name in my example.
So I'm using the positional
because I'm lazy.
And then I'm executing that.
And as I can see,
then hopefully,
if I didn't do any mistakes,
I will see some events coming
up down here, as you can see.
So I have all my multievents
that are happening from today
to tomorrow.
Now, I talked about
time-bounded queries.
So one thing that I can do
in my read-only transactions,
I can actually add
timestamp bound,
which sets the maximal staleness
that allow for a query.
So I have to edit this here.
And if I execute that
again or run this again,
it goes against the read
replica and can directly
serve that data from
the read replica
without basically consulting
the leader of the Paxos crew.
The next thing
that I want to show
is how the write looks like.
So if I have a
write-only transaction,
I basically work with mutations.
Now, what is a mutation?
A mutation is basically
any changes in my tables.
And you have to look at
mutations as on cell level.
So in transaction, we support
up to 20,000 mutations.
If you have a table
with five columns
and you load one row into
this col-- in this table,
you have five mutations.
If you have to find an index
on that table with another two
columns, and you insert
one row, you basically
have seven mutations.
Now, here, in this
case, I basically
add an account in my table.
And I run that.
If we go back to my database,
and go my demo instance,
and go to my account,
and go and preview,
we see that I have
inserted, here, an account.
Now, the next thing, if you want
to do a read/write transaction,
you basically obtain
a transaction runner
that we can see here.
So basically, we execute or
rerun a read/write transaction.
And through that
read/write transaction,
we provide a transaction
callable from a transaction
runner.
So basically, it's
a function that you
give to that run function.
And in this run
function, you define
what you want to do in terms of
reading and updating your data.
So in this case, I'm
selecting my account.
I'm updating the
name of my account.
And then I'm adding these
mutations to my transaction
and run this transaction.
Now, why are we doing this
in a transaction runnable?
The reason is that our client
libraries do automatic retries
of transactions if they fail.
So this makes it easier
for us to basically do
the recovery from
failed transactions
and rerun them again.
So now if I go to my database
and check the preview,
again, you see that
I updated my name.
All right.
With this, I'm going
back to the slides.
So the last thing that
I want to talk about
from the slides, once
we switch, is the--
in terms of how does Spanner
fit into the storage portfolio
that we have on
our cloud platform,
so I want to just mention
a couple of things here.
When do you use Spanner?
I just wanted to reiterate
there are two major use
cases for Spanner.
If you need a high
available system which
scales horizontally for
transactional workloads
and reads and writes,
Spanner is your way to go.
Even if you have a low amount
of data, you can use it.
Also, if you have a
lot of data that you
want to scale
basically horizontally,
again, that is a way
to go for Spanner.
We have a lot of other options
under the Google Cloud platform
portfolio.
If you come from a
MySQL or Postgres world,
we have a managed service
called Cloud SQL, which
you can move through,
basically, as lift and shift
if you want to.
If you are looking at a
more NoSQL world, where
you have data that
is document based,
you are looking at
Cloud Datastore.
Or if you have key
value based workloads,
which need very low latencies
for reads and writes
and high scalability, you
look at Cloud Bigtable.
If you have things
like blobstores,
like videos, photos, things
like that, or any kind of files,
you look into the
cloud storage world.
And if you want to do data
analytics or relational data,
so basically data warehouse
applications or scenarios,
you look into BigQuery, which
is our distributed and very
scalable data warehouse
for relational data.
With this, thank you very much.
And I hope you
enjoyed the session.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.